hi this is a month bajaj from electrical
limited and it has been a very nice
experience and exciting specially
because this is the first time that the
India economic summit has taken place in
Mumbai in 27 years and I have
particularly powdered interesting with a
variety of subjects that has been
covered this time and I believe we need
to have a further dialogue on various
issues but I found it very interesting
that the Globus global issues like
corruption and especially leadership has
been focused very strongly and that has
been very useful for myself specifically
to understand how these leadership
aspects are going to be taken forward
and I wish there is further of other
India economic summits in Mumbai the
future and is not just a one off all the
best and